when we rose to crush the fallen it was
I who showed them mercy house wolf
starts with betrayal
the house of wolves have risen up
against the Queen and attacked her
guards and now the queen is deciding to
make a change to open up the reef for
all guardians to come and collect bounty
no they will feel my wrath attention
Guardians this is pet revenge of the
awoken Royal Guard throughout the story
Petra she's the voice for the Queen
she'll be sending on the main story
missions to hunt down the main bad guy
stole off I'm the queen's blade your
hunt begins with me rather than just
have the one story character we
introduced a whole new area the social
space of the reef take a look around
you'll find some interesting allies here
there are multiple different characters
in there each with their own perspective
I can help you find the wolves
you just have to go to the reef and seem
new quest givers that's a really
interesting way to both expand the
universe and tell a compelling story
the team really wanted to explore and
more activities for the player weapons
armor and gear to earn house of wolves
will spend forever once you've completed
the story the prison of elders opens up
to you and barracks is your guide
through that it's a gladiator arena
inside this prison were the most
nefarious criminals in the universe live
the arena is all about getting straight
to the action you can match make into it
using all of your weapons and all of
your skills night ki safai
you want to ratchet up the difficulty to
an ultra hard difficulty mode that you
need to form a fireteam the rewards of
course ratchet up as well
we have brother Vance who is a vendor
specifically for the trials of Osiris
the Wolves will test them make them
ready for the trials
trials of Osiris provides the PvP end
game experience so players can go up
against the best in the world and get
rewarded with the best gear the
elimination game type is probably the
most intense game type we have a destiny
right now you bring your pre-made fire
team 3v3 no response so you're trying to
wipe out the enemy team when they're all
dead rounds over so there's three new
pvp maps in house of wolves blackshield
widows court and thieves den black
shield takes place on Phobos one of
Mars's moons it's a banyan cabal outpost
it tends to play really well for control
and also nicely for skirmish widows
Court is an asymmetrical map that takes
place in the European dead zone and it
features long sniper lines as well as
close quarters battle thieves den takes
place in an abandoned fallen outpost in
an active volcano the really interesting
part is the center of the map that you
end up fighting on and around quite a
bit because it's the focal point and the
midline
the new strike is called the shadow
thief and it takes place on the Fallen
catch on the moon
you're tracking another fallen captain
who's gone rogue you meet him several
times he talks you up so it's not just
about waves of enemies it's not just
about one collating boss battle
a lot of people want to take their fate
bringer or their weapons or gear from
the vault of glass or crotas end and
they want to still use it to all
legendary dear weapons armor can be
brought up to level 34
house of wolves offers players tons of
new variety new guns new gear is really
important we want a new exotics out in
mixed Queens wrath is returning you got
ball and theme stuff Cyrus theme stuff
great thing about destiny is it doesn't
stop with house of wolves you're
building this character that is going to
persist into the future let the hunt
begin
you